[Music]
are you [ __ ] tired of being
[ __ ] rich as hell no we're the
mansions yeah
no no you're so rich yeah we're the
manchester you're the right you're the
mansion sitter
are you tired of watching other people's
homes
and you're lonely in there well guess
what i'm gonna give you this new product
it's called the phone bone and this is
how you do this
when you're sitting for the mansions and
you're waiting for people
you can phone bone at any room so you
don't come all over their mansion
what the [ __ ] yeah it's like phone sex
service
but then hold on let me read this [ __ ]
i'm too panicky you have five seconds
no what you have a question for me i
just wanted to say what a troubled man
what's
what are you what are you gonna eat
tonight when you get home oh
[ __ ] after my fight club
[Laughter]
because you know i'm just gonna be
eating vegan
cuisines what the [ __ ] is going on in
this country
it's pretty [ __ ] up if you get it i'd
be surprised and musical
la chalupa is that that one
el gallo
[Music]
that's what i know
oh [ __ ] a blonde girl uh black girl best
friends
what do you say long girl and black girl
i said baby oh that's clueless
one of the best movies ever made
absolutely so good
as if [ __ ] whatever three